day one of ces the super bowl of
technology officially in the books
we saw it all i mean there was some
really cool stuff uh human-like robots a
car that has color changing technology
that's not in the books yet obviously
still has to go until tomorrow the trade
show has had some challenges because of
the coronavirus and some major tech
companies are not here they're virtual
instead because of what's going on with
the pandemic hector mojito is live
inside the convention center this
morning with some highlights and some
new tech hector good morning
good morning guys and again the health
took the spotlight here at ces from some
of the uh technology that they're
showcasing to the protocols in place
this year joining us live we have tina
to explain what it's like and what it's
been like at least for the first day to
attend ces during the pandemic good
morning good morning thank you for
having us so ces is so happy to be back
home in las vegas but yes it does look a
little different now the footprint of
the show is a little smaller and we are
taking a much more layered approach to
our security protocols and safety give
us a brief highlight of yesterday
absolutely so yesterday was the first
day of the show
we had great energy we had our opening
keynote from gary shapiro we had gm come
on stage and talk about all the great
innovation and autonomous vehicles and
electric vehicles they're really doing a
big push for sustainability which was
something else we saw from the samsung
keynote the night before all right so we
kind of have to talk about this is
pretty cool just describe exactly what
this is it kind of looks like a mouth
guard it does but it's actually a
toothbrush
i know and it will clean your teeth
including your entire dental arch um
with no water or toothpaste how does
that work but let's open it let's see
can we see what's inside yes yes so it
looks like again like you said a mouth
guard which we're gonna keep wrapped to
keep it clean um that you'll put into
your mouth and it uses additives um and
plugs into here so i think this is great
if you're camping or you know you need
to freshen up your teeth without water
or maybe stuck at the airport with
delays stuck at the airport delays stuck
on the road
here you go all right thank you so much
but lastly uh you know going back to
healthy you guys you know we've had
issues with other trade shows in town
not enforcing the mass mandate how are
you guys making sure that does get done
absolutely so we have health ambassadors
on the show floor who are going to be
handing people a mask who need them
so that's a really big priority for us
is adhering to nevada state laws awesome
tina thank you very much so we'll be
back in half an hour with a few more
products to showcase for now reporting
live hector mejia live local now back to
you guys